muchas veces intenté salir con alguien
porque todos lo hacían pero siempre fui
sincera así como hola soy asexual quizás
no sea tu tipo y ellos serán como no
importa entiendo totalmente tres meses
después hacían un drama total porque no
quería besarnos spectrum todos los
asexuales piensan lo mismo
[Música]
spectrum asexuales e incluso siendo
asexual he experimentado atracción
321 ahora
esperen no no lo hice correctamente
bueno la verdad es que sí lo siento me
disculpo con todos hay momentos en mi
vida que estoy como esto es atracción o
como está pasando algo aquí pero la
mayoría del tiempo pienso que alguien es
bonito pero no siento ese conjunto de
cosas la verdad la verdad no la
sexualidad es un espectro muy amplio
bajo ese espectro yo caigo en algo que
llamo de mi sexualidad lo que
básicamente significa que necesito un
sentimiento muy fuerte y netamente
emocional antes de sentir algún tipo de
atracción sexual puedo mirar a alguien y
decir esta persona es atractiva pero no
siento atracción sexual o el impulso de
querer salir con esa persona
creo que hay diferentes formas de
atracción quizás me gustan las personas
estéticamente perfectas pero realmente
no siento una atracción romántica me
masturbo con regularidad
321 ahora
creo que voy primero la forma en la que
he sido capaz de conocer a mucha gente
en la comunidad de asexuales es a través
de los kings así que si usualmente me
masturbo pero siempre está relacionado
con la comunidad que en que lo hago
regularmente pero no es algo de un deseo
sexual intenso o que quiere encontrar
sexo o un atractivo sexual yo me siento
caliente muy a menudo ya sabes pero
cuando pasa es como bien siento que es
algo científico y es tipo tengo tengo
que aliviar esta sensación hacer algo
creo que consume mucho tiempo quiero
decir hay programas en la televisión que
quiero ver
yo pienso que no hay necesito eso si
tengo ganas de algo pues creo que lo
reemplazó comiendo o algo así
[Risas]
personalmente cuando surgen las ganas no
es algo que disfruto es molesta las
personas sexuales
porque no experimentan atracción no
significa que no tienen libido sexual es
decir puedes seguir teniendo estos
impulsos algunas veces pero siento que
la comunidad asexual
no es restarle importancia pero tampoco
significa que sea algo indispensable y
que lo tengas que hacer porque si ya me
da curiosidad saber lo que piensan sobre
una persona como yo que está en el lado
opuesto del espectro cómo lo ven
siendo asexual yo pienso que una líbido
alta no significa atracciones son ser
cosas distintas
yo no lo entiendo pero lo respeto y
encuentro el sexo repulsivo
321 ahora
para mí creo que está bien creo que hay
otras maneras de ganar atracción porque
al final del día no tiene que ser algo
enteramente sexual puedes hallar muchas
otras cosas sería algo fijado en
apariencia o algo más estoy en la parte
gris de este espectro de la asexualidad
todos tenemos esos días no hay días en
que me siento así días en que es más
fuerte y días en que no siento nada es
muchas personas se comunican a través
del sexo esa es su forma de mostrar sus
emociones aunque eso no es para mí
pienso que depende de quién sea la
persona porque se supone que debes ser
capaz de confiar en alguien y si no es
el caso que tan bueno sería que lo
hicieras entiende yo sí siento ganas de
tener sexo como demi sexual el no estar
conectado emocional o intelectualmente
con el otro me desagrada mucho
simplemente no lo quiero no me repugna
que otras personas lo hagan porque cada
quien puede hacer lo que quiera solo que
yo no me veo
y participando en algo como eso la
asexualidad se trata esencialmente de la
atracción no de la acción no puedes
experimentar esa atracción y seguir como
que todo esto se siente bien para mí el
sexo es una actividad normal que tú
haces así como gracias a alguien o le
das la mano en mi opinión no tiene otro
nivel o por lo menos no ese nivel que la
sociedad quiere darle para mí es como no
es una actividad que hagas con alguna
persona como si eso fuera lo más
importante exacto
soy virgen
321 ahora
es un poco lo que esperaba para mí el
sexo no es como la gente siempre habla
de eso y yo me siento como bueno eso no
es realmente atractivo tengo amigos que
me apoyan pasatiempos que puedo hacer y
prefiero encontrar algo más que hacer
con mi tiempo muchas veces intenté salir
con alguien porque todos lo hacían pero
siempre fui sincera así como hola soy
asexual quizás no sea tu tipo y ellos
eran como no importa entiendo totalmente
tres meses después hacían un drama total
porque no quería besarlo
he tenido relaciones de pareja antes
tanto con hombres como con mujeres y si
he tenido sexo con mis dos parejas así
que si no soy virgen y cuando cuando
perdiste tu virginidad y yo perdí mi
virginidad cuando tenía como 16 o 17 que
me dice ese tipo tenía tenía 17 años
cuando perdí la mía
y no es la mejor historia mi novia en
ese momento me obligó a me obligó a
tener relaciones sexuales
perdí mi virginidad porque ella decía si
me amarás entonces tendría sexo conmigo
y en ese momento pensé está bien esta es
mi primera relación y no quiero no no
quiero no quiero tener sexo con ella
pero tengo miedo de que termine conmigo
porque no quiero tener sexo
si de verdad es algo muy fuerte si es el
indicado tú quisieras que se quedara
contigo para siempre quisiera abrazarte
estamos también de trapo ya te felicito
por haber pasado por eso y haberte
encontrado a ti mismo y ser quien eres
hoy quisiera abrazarte pero no sé si
puedo
[Risas]
gracias quiero decir personalmente nunca
he experimentado nada de eso yo no
desearía poder experimentar el sexo pero
hay momentos en los que desearía no ser
asexual
los ves ahora también voy a llorar está
tan arraigado en nuestra sociedad que
deberías tener atracción tener atracción
romántica o atracción sexual entonces
muchos de nosotros si no tenemos la
palabra nos sentimos tan destrozados
hasta que la encontramos
tuve mucha suerte porque tuve un padre
que sabía cuál era la palabra de hecho
mi mamá dijo quizá eres asexual no
sientes esas cosas y está bien pero
mucha gente no tiene esa palabra
me siento invisible para la comunidad
lgtb de cu plus 321 ahora
la comunidad lgtb de cv en sí es
bastante sexualizada por ejemplo el día
del orgullo es es muy sexual creo que es
muy difícil para ellos incluir una
sexualidad que es la ausencia de ella
misma
he escuchado a mucha gente decir que los
asexuales no son tan oprimidos como las
otras personas de la comunidad del
genético pero es que la comunidad no es
solo para eso no es sólo estar oprimido
que tu familia no te apoye estamos
experimentando cosas diferentes del
resto del mundo y se siente mucho mejor
cuando tienes a una comunidad contigo
apoyándote para mí esta pregunta es un
poco personal ya que lo más cercano para
mí fue mi tía ya que ella es lesbiana en
cuanto a las relaciones con la familia
todo el mundo acepta mi tía pero cuando
se trata de mí es como tú no existes aún
no lo has probado me hace sentir un poco
vacía porque tú eres mi familia se
supone que deberías estar conmigo y
también deberías poder consolarme
como dices el orgullo está realmente
sexualizado y ser positivo al sexo y
alentar a las personas a tener tanto
sexo como quieran también significa que
no quieran tener nada de sexo la gente
dice lo que experimentas es válido pero
no eres tan queer como para estar en la
comunidad entonces que realmente ser
queer como alguien que se identifica
como que realmente quería escuchar todo
lo que estaban diciendo porque estoy
completamente de acuerdo con todo lo que
acaban de decir acabo de estar en el
sitio web
lg y enumeran una lista completa de
diferentes identidades asexuales nos
estamos volviendo un poco más abiertos
al respecto pero no quiero dar demasiado
crédito porque estoy 100% de acuerdo en
que falta mucho trabajo en la comunidad
tener mayor visibilidad es genial de
verdad es muy bueno pero siguen siendo
sólo los de la comunidad asexual y no
hay nadie o hay muy pocas personas
comparado con la comunidad queer que
siempre pide que nos involucremos yo
conozco algunas personas que simplemente
sienten que
pertenecen a la comunidad por lo que se
adhieren básicamente a una comunidad
hace si no sé ustedes pero cuando iba a
una reunión o cosas así me preguntaba si
los asexuales éramos bienvenidos
así que supongo que si somos una buena
comunidad es definitivamente por
internet ya que recuerdo haber visto
este programa llamado voy a course man y
cuando descubrí que uno de los
personajes principales todo era asexual
pensé oh vaya aquí hay alguien en el
espacio real de los medios con quien
realmente puedo identificarme al final
del día y no se le mostró como un caso
de alguien que necesita rehabilitación
porque generalmente cuando alguien de
los medios es asexual es porque tiene
algo mal si realmente encontramos
comunidad a través de internet nunca
había estado con tantas personas
asexuales en toda mi vida todavía estoy
explorando mi sexualidad
321 ahora
solía identificarme con demi lovato y
luego se case y fue como que es
realmente esto con lo que me quiero
identificar
todavía no estoy segura de mí misma no
sé cuáles son mis propios sentimientos
la mitad del tiempo y todavía soy joven
y estoy tratando de estar de acuerdo con
no saber realmente algunas cosas sobre
mí al menos por ahora me gusta cómo
estoy ahora creo que uno de los
conceptos erróneos sobre la comunidad
hace es que la gente se te acercará y
pensará que no tienes experiencia que no
sabes lo que estás buscando o que eres
demasiado joven y lo descubrirás y eso
no es así especialmente en mi caso
siento que no tengo mucha experiencia y
sé lo que me gusta y lo que no
pero al mismo tiempo creo que todavía
estoy explorando un poco para mí estoy
en la sección en desacuerdo porque
siento que soy bastante sólida en mi
identidad hay momentos en los que pienso
eso fue atracción que fue eso pero no
importa lo que haya sido no va a cambiar
mi comportamiento siento que en este
punto ya sé lo que quiero y estoy tan
harta de que otras personas me juzguen
por ello saben
me quedaré aquí en mi pequeña burbuja me
siento muy cómoda estando aquí he tenido
esta seguridad desde los días estoy
segura de que mi madre probablemente
pensó que lo superaría que yo había
crecido tarde o algo pero a medida que
crecía seguía firme en mi posición a mi
persona cuando tenía 11 o 12 años cuando
escuché eso por primera vez cuando
descubrí que es la sexualidad en contra
el access y pensé está bien soy yo
sexual pero cuando llegué a la
secundaria fue como puede ser
heterosexual o algo todos lo son y pensé
está bien no tal vez soy gay porque no
soy heterosexual no escuché que la
universidad y dije quizás soy bea' o sí
exacto estás como los dos lados
sólo en los últimos meses finalmente
volvió a ser asexual es una etiqueta
amplia y puede estar cómoda bajo ese
paraguas
[Risas]
genial cambiar instagram